- Lentement, péniblement,
Ousama Al Kolak revient
à la maison. Du moins,
ce qu'il en reste.
Là où s'élevait, il y a un peu
plus d'une semaine, l'immeuble
de cinq étages construit par
son grand-père, ne reste plus
qu'une tonne de gravats.
Quatre décennies d'histoire
familiale réduites en poussière.
La nuit du 16 mai, tout le clan
Al Kolak s'était réfugié ici
pour se mettre à l'abri
de l'intense campagne
de bombardements.
"C'était tellement intense que
la maison en tremblait", dit-il.
À 1 h 30 du matin, il entend
une énorme déflagration
et tout s'effondre.
Miraculé, il n'a que
des blessures mineures.
Mais quand il sort des
décombres, il prend conscience
de l'ampleur du désastre.
Il dit avoir perdu
son grand-père, sa grand-mère,
sa mère, deux de ses frères,
des cousins, leurs enfants...
Une liste sans fin.
En tout, 22 personnes fauchées
d'un seul coup.
"On me dit que la vie doit
continuer, dit-il, mais
on ne peut pas se remettre
d'avoir perdu tant de proches."
Mais cette tragédie est
loin d'être un cas isolé.
Car dans la même rue,
la même nuit, au même moment
où s'effondrait la maison
des Al Kolak, cet immeuble
s'écroulait lui aussi.
Et sous ses décombres,
23 personnes, dont 16 membres
de la même famille.
Venu se rendre compte par
lui-même de l'ampleur du drame,
l'ancien candidat à
la présidence palestinienne
Moustapha Barghouti est
sous le choc.
La rue Al Wahda était
auparavant une artère
commerciale très animée de Gaza.
Ce n'est plus aujourd'hui
qu'un champ de ruines.
Et ce n'est pas